joining me now is New York Congressman
Lee zeldin all right congressman
I want you to play koi tonight okay no
Coy Lee all right we want the straight
shooter Lee zeldin that managed to help
flip all those seats in New York
will you run for RNC chair yes or no
well right now I am seriously
considering it I have not decided
however I am not a procrastinator so I
want to very quickly decide whether or
not to make this run what I do know is
that it is important for the Republican
party with this opportunity to retool to
transform because we have high stakes
races coming up in 24 for president of
the United States we need to elect more
Republicans to the house and the Senate
and down ballot candidates who need to
get elected as well so what I do know
for sure is that I'm committed to doing
absolutely everything in my power to
ensure that we save our country we have
a country that needs to be saved and I
plan on doing my part I am very
seriously considering a run for chair of
the Republican National Committee
well what what factors do you need to
still consider I mean seems like you've
thought about it really carefully so
again why the hesitation
so right now I've been communicating
with the RNC delegates there's 168 of
them who have a vote many of them have
reached out to me encouraging me to run
and that's why we're here at this point
making this announcement and having this
conversation uh they have to you need a
majority vote and if a majority of the
vote wants to continue with the the
status quo then we'll continue with the
status quo if a majority of these 168
Republican National Committee delegates
want to go in a different direction well
then that's where we have an important
role to play and I believe that there's
an opportunity with messaging and
Communications with fundraising and
expenditures with ensuring that it's
organization it's collaboration we have
to look at election Integrity candidate
Recruitment and ensuring that when
you're trying to create a movement
energy enthusiasm you have to not just
say what you're against yeah we're
against Joe Biden we're against the
Democratic party okay what are we for
we're four
yeah exactly and what we are for is
expressing to these Americans that we
want to do everything in our power to
save America while these Democrats are
doing everything in their power to save
themselves there are attacks right now
on security we see it at our border and
in our cities and is now spilled into
the suburbs attacks on wallets and
restriction on opportunities for
prosperity and more Economic Opportunity
a tax on our education and we have to
reverse
is running for another term as RNC chair
and she already says she has the support
of I guess a hundred or so of the RNC
members
so do you think she deserves another
term how do you rate her performance as
RNC chair
well if she she doesn't have a hundred I
mean that's clear from all the calls
that I've been receiving I think that
that was a massive rounding up I've
worked well uh with with Rana
um we've gotten along well uh I I'm a
military guy you know you put someone in
a position for two three four years they
start doing a fantastic job and you
promote them you move them to some other
job and you bring in new ideas new
energy and fresh perspective I happen to
be somebody who's in favor of term
limits I'm leaving the House of
Representatives after four terms in
eight years and I believe that our
founding father's intent was that you
come to Congress you bring your ideas
your energy you try to make a difference
and then you move on so I think that
there's something to benefit from
understanding that you can't be
when can we expect a decision from you
this is something that we want to figure
out in a matter of days this isn't a
matter of weeks
okay Congressman zeldon it's great to
see you tonight thank you so much for
joining us we'll be watching very
closely hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else